hey guys it's Jonah here nothing says
good morning like a freshly cooked warm
bowl of oatmeal so besides the
traditional way of consuming oatmeal I'm
going to share with you four very easy
and delicious ways to add oats into your
breakfast to me breakfast is the most
important meal of the day
having a healthy and hearty breakfast
gets my metabolism pumping it keeps me
energized and it really does benefit me
in making healthy choices throughout the
day so while the slow cooked and creamy
blended into fruit smoothie or added
into energy bars oats provide your body
with lots of health benefits it is high
in fiber high in protein low in fat and
low in calories for men you should be
getting between thirty to thirty eight
grams of fiber in a day and 21 to 25
grams of fiber for ladies one cup of
cold milk contains about 150 calories
salmon group of protein and five gram of
fiber oatmeal is also known to lower LDL
or also known as your bad cholesterol
levels without affecting your good
cholesterol levels and because oatmeal
is a great source of fiber it is also
known to lower your body weight having
oatmeal for breakfast will keep you
satisfied for much longer
hence eating last throughout the day a
bowl of oat milk can easily last you to
lunchtime without feeling peckish a
high-fiber diet
stabilizing blood sugar levels providing
you with a steady release of energy
throughout the day and this will not
cause those mid-morning slaps unlike a
heavy breakfast hide in sugar and fat
which may leave you feeling bloated and
sluggish oatmeal is very soothing to the
digestive process it is very feeling yet
light and it keeps your tummy happy all
my recipes are very much adaptable so
just follow the basics put your creative
hat on pick your favorite ingredients
and experiment with your own flavors so
let us start with the sloppy overnight
oatmeal so if you're someone who rush
out of bed - out of the front door and
have absolutely no type of breakfast
well why don't have your breakfast at
the 94 because if you fail to plan well
you plan to fail so no matter how busy
you are take a little bit of initiative
and plan your breakfast time to call
these at least stopping overnight
oatmeal because it is so easy to make it
takes only five minutes of your time and
there is absolutely no cooking required
so make this the night before and wake
up to a hearty breakfast the next
morning the ingredients I've used are
half a cup of oats 1/2 a cup of any milk
of your choice 1 tablespoon of goji
berries 1 teaspoon of chasings or any
other super
of your choice have a cup of
strawberries sliced and half the cup of
grapes or again any fruits of your
choice in a bowl mix oats milk goji
berries and share seats together now
let's assemble this sloppy overnight
oatmeal either in a glass or jar so lay
the bottom with half of the oat mixture
then add in half of your fruits so mine
will be strawberries and grapes and mix
in the remaining oat mixture finally top
it out with the remaining fruits place
this sloppy oatmeal in the fridge
overnight and serve it for breakfast the
next morning the chair seeds will give
it a thick and creamy texture and the
natural sweetness from the fruits will
sit into the oat mixture which makes it
really sweet without any added sugar
this sloppy looking breakfast is so
yummy and it will keep is satisfied
until lunch time you can even make
several classes and store them in the
fridge for the next few morning's not
more than three days before eating so be
creative
pick your own fruits and create your own
flavors so busy people there is
absolutely no excuse to make this sloppy
overnight oatmeal the next ultimate
breakfast can also double up as an
energy bar if you have been following me
on Facebook and Instagram you will also
know that this is one of my favorite
snacks they are so yummy and I have to
control myself from finishing all of
them at once it is so easy to make only
three ingredients and no baking is
required the three main ingredients are
1 cup of rolled oats dry and uncle
half a cup of peanut butter and quarter
cup of maple syrup or honey with the
three basic ingredients you can choose
to add additional topics such as
seeds nuts dried fruit chocolate chips
cocoa powder ground cinnamon lemon zest
basically anything to your liking for
this recipe I've added one tablespoon of
unsweetened cocoa powder and one
tablespoon of sunflower seeds in a pan
melt the peanut butter and maple syrup
together under low heat until smooth
don't cook then turn the heat off add in
the oats cocoa powder and sunflower
seeds combined well next transfer and
press the mixture into a middle square
tip or plate then place it in the fridge
for about 1 hour all ends your phone
once firmed slice the energy bar into
nice squares this healthy Hood squares
are so easy to be eaten and they will
provide you with enough energy
throughout the whole morning
store them in a fridge to keep them firm
and they will last up to a week you can
pack them out have them all the way to
work or even as a mid-afternoon snack
for a quick energy boost another really
easy way to add oats into a diet is to
add them into smoothies smoothies makes
a really quick refreshing and filling
breakfast as well be sure to watch my
video here to make a pulp a green
smoothie
also fruit smoothie once you know the
basic you can keep experimenting with
different fruits and toppings and you
will never drink the same flavor of
smoothies again I like to keep my
smoothies rather simple so for my
sunrise sportsman smoothie I've used one
frozen medium banana sliced 1/2 a cup of
frozen mango sliced into cubes 1/2 a cup
of coconut water and quite a cup of
rolled oats to get a nice consistent
texture start by blending the oats until
finely ground then add the remaining
ingredients frozen banana mango and
coconut water pulse until blended and
smooth voila breakfast is served
this delicious glass of sunrise Ultima
smoothie is packed with fiber and flavor
it feels you're up yet at the same time
it doesn't leave your tummy feeling
heavy and bloated especially in the
morning so if you're not really a
breakfast type of person or if you
prefer to drink your breakfast then have
smoothies for breakfast and be sure to
add oats for the added benefits and of
course the most common way to have oats
is a freshly cooked one bowl of oatmeal
this is your mole you can literally add
anything into it for instance a mixture
of fresh fruits trail of dried fruits
nuts seeds Jen peanut butter sweeten it
with honey or maple syrup make it
chocolaty with cocoa powder and protein
powder or make a savory by adding an egg
you can even turn it into a country by
cooking it with fish slices or chicken
basically whatever you like you can add
it in so being creative
we have entries and try different
toppings all I'm going to say is give
coats a chance and I can assure you in
no time you will be hooked so try this
recipes out let me know which is your
favorite in the comments below and be
sure to share your creation with me on
Facebook and Instagram all the best for
new Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
You Tube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys